- So right now, I'm driving downtown
to go do a rehearsal for Vlog University.
It's happening tomorrow.
Depending on when you're watching it,
it might be happening right now,
and of course, it's Los
Angeles, so there's traffic.
(calm piano music)
Made it downtown to the convention center.
We're about to head in and go
start setting up for tomorrow.
(calm music)
Guys, look, this is the banner.
Vlog University is here.
This is so exciting.
So everything is still
being set up for tomorrow.
This is our little
check in desk.
- Whoa, whoa, no filming.
No filming.
(Justine laughs)
- They told me not film
because it looks messy
and this isn't what it's gonna look like,
but I was like, this is us vlogging.
This is what we do.
We film behind the scenes,
but I wanna show you guys,
this what I'm really excited about.
Okay, come, come, come.
We have so much fun Vlog U swag.
We have pink water bottles.
They had a bunch of different colors,
but as soon as I saw this hot pink,
I knew immediately we needed this one.
We also got a little backpack.
Do I look like I'm going to school?
(calm music)
Vlog U pens.
We also have some tote bags.
I don't know where I'm going,
I'm just walking.
(calm music)
Here's some of our sponsors,
so thank you, guys.
Over here is one of the breakout rooms.
We're gonna be having panels and sessions,
and everything is not set up yet.
Oh, wow, look at this.
Whoa, there's lots of seats.
I'm excited to see this tomorrow.
It's gonna be a surprise to me
because I don't even know 100%
what it's gonna look like.
We've seen pictures,
we've talked about things,
but you never actually
know until the day of,
so you guys are gonna get to see it.
What's over here?
Oh, here's another little room.
I just keep thinking about
how crazy it is that this whole thing
started from a little YouTube show
that I started 10 years ago.
There's still tickets if
you wanna get them online,
so make sure you check
out vloguniversity.com
and we're gonna be here all weekend,
so hope to see you guys.
(calm music)
Here's the red carpet.
We're gonna roll it out.
(low shuffling)
(calm music)
Do it for the 'gram or
the TikTok or the Byte.
(Justine laughs)
Oh, this is not that fun.
(Justine grunts)
Got the shot.
♪ Roll out ♪
♪ Me and my homies ♪
(mellow music)
- So here's the theater
where the keynote's gonna be happening.
I'm so excited.
My friend Josh Sundquist,
who I'm sure most of you guys know
here on YouTube, he's incredible.
He's gonna be also doing the keynote
and I can't believe it.
It's crazy because I met him,
oh my gosh, at the first Vidcon.
So that fact that he's
now here doing the keynote
at Vlog University's so great.
All right, it's go time.
(mellow music)